[موسيقى]
طب توقعاتكم واهلا وسهلا بكم في حوار
فرانس 24 ضيفنا هو وزير الداخليه
والبلديات اللبنانيه بسام مولوي اهلا
وسهلا بك اهلا بكم اهلا بكم الطبيعه تكره
الفراغ
الى متى سيظل هذا الفراغ في رئاسه
في لبنان في موقع الرئاسه الاولى وليست
حاله فراغ في موقع الحكم اذا انه بحسب
الدستور تتولى الحكومه
مهام رئيس الجمهوريه في حال خلو سده
الرئاسه بحسب اللفظ الدستوري همم
يتمكن الساده النواب الكرام من انتخاب
رئيس جمهوريه يكون رئيس وهنا نتمنى ان
يكون رئيس الجمهوريه على صوره
مستقبل لبنان على صوره لبنان الغد الذي
نريده ويكون لديه رؤيه طموحه جواك يبقى
المتغيرات الكبيره التي تحصل في المنطقه
وفي العالم
وتكون على قدر الوضع غير الصحي وغير الجيد
الذي يعيشه لبنان واللبنانيون الى صعيد
الاداره العامه او غير على صعيد المؤسسات
او على صعيد الوضع الاقتصادي او على
الصعيد الوضع المعيشي او في كل القطاعات
نحن بحاجه لرئيس تكون لديه رؤيه انقاذيه
وبالتالي لا يكون على صوره ومثال من سبقوه
ويكون نهجه تماما مختلف
الانقسامات داخل مجلس النواب
اه محاوله ان محاوله انتاج رئيس جمهوريه
على
على المقاس او على الطريقه التي سبق على
مقاس بعض الاطراف محاوله انتاج رئيس
جمهوريه على مقاس بعض الاطراف او وفق
الطريقه التي كانت تنتج في فترات سابقه
وهذا انا اجده ليس من مصلحه لبنان
ولبنانيون في الشيء طيب الى ترسيم الحدود
الان بين لبنان
لولا موافقت حزب الله كان بالامكان التوصل
لهذا الاتفاق ان المفاوضات حول ترسيم
الحدود قام بها الرؤساء الثلاثاء في لبنان
همم وان كافه الاتفاقات والمواثيق الدوليه
التي تعود بالمصلحه لبنان يجب ان تمر مهما
كان الامر ونحن لا نقول همم وان كان البعض
يستغل ااا
اتفاقيه معينه ليظهر بمظهر المنتصر في
مكان معين وانما نحن نبحث عن نصر لبنان
وليس عن نصر لاحد او لطرف من الاطراف
وبالاخص ليس نصرا للاستغلال في حال كان
بالفعل هذا الامر هو بمثابه النصر انما
يجب استكمال هذه الخطوه بحيث يستطيع لبنان
من همم استخراج
الثرواته من الغاز او من النفوس والاهم ان
يكون السيستام ان تكون المنظومه التي تكون
تشرف على هذا الموضوع وعلى السياسه
والاقتصاد في البلد همم في حينه همم على
المستوى المطلوب على اوتيل على المستوى
المطلوب لكي يحقق لاننا نعرف انها هناك
الكثير من الدول النفطيه التي تعاني من
وضع اقتصادي سيء مثل لبنان واكثر سوءا ذلك
يتعلق بمنظومه الفساد التي تكون موجوده في
مثل هذه الدول لبنان يجب ان يخرج من هذه
التجربه منتصرا لشعبه منتصرا لدولته همم
يجب ان تسود لبنان في الفتره القادمه منطق
الدوله ومنطق الشرعيه ويجب ان من الدوله
ليس بمثابه اعتراف
ترسيم الحدود هو اتفاق قام به الرؤساء
الثلاثاء وكما قالوا وحسب ما قالوا هو ضمن
اطار همم
محدود استخراج الغاز
الشرعيه في لبنان ومن دعاه بناء الدوله
وانا قلتها في اكثر من مره وفي المره
الاخيره
خارج الشرعيه
ما هو ليس شرعي ليس شرعيا لا اعتبره لا لا
اعتبره مشروعا وبالتالي يجب ان تنضوي كل
الاطر السياسيه ضمن اطار الدوله الشرعيه
نحن من همم ننادي بالدوله الشرعيه ونحن
نتعامل في وزاره الداخليه مع كل الامور
منطلق الدوله الشرعيه ومن منطلق
متطلبات شرعيه الدوله بحيث لا لا لا لا لا
لا نقوم باي امر سوى من هذا المنطلق همم
وليس لدينا همم اي همم اي تعاطي مع ايطار
خارجي اطار الدوله اللبنانيه الشرعيه ماذا
تجيب على من يقول ان ترسيم الحدود مع
سوريا سيكون اصعب من ترتيب الحدود مع
اسرائيل
ان ترسيم الحدود القادم مع سوريا ومع قبرص
هو عمر دقيق وسيكون امر بغايه الدقه ونامل
ان لا يكون صعبا
انما كل هذه الامور تعتبها بعض الصعوبات
الامر يتعلق بالوضع السياسي الذي سيكون
قائما حينها من هنا كانت مناداهنا برئيس
جمهوريه وبحكم متكامل همم يعرف مصلحه
لبنان
ويتقيد باثر الشرعيه اللبنانيه ليحقق
للشعب اللبناني مصالحه اذا زاد للقول
المهجوره ههه طيب هل هناك تخوف احيانا
الوضع الامني بسبب تعكر الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في لبنان
الوضع الامني هو الوضع الاسلم في لبنان
نحن نعاني من ضائقه اقتصاديه ومن مشاكل
فيها كبيره من همم نعاني من وجود همم
النازحين السوريين بكميات وباعداد كبيره
بحيث الناس
ما يتجاوز ثلث الموجودين على الاراضي
دونينه اللبنانيه هم من غير اللبنانيين
بالنسبه للجريمه نحن نراقب ذلك يوميا لا
يوجد ارتفاع نسبه الجريمه في لبنان بحيث
ان جرائم القتل هي اقل جرائم القطف هي اقل
لم ترتفع سوى جرائم النشر او بعض السرقات
البسيطه القوه الامنيه انطلاقا وبالرغم من
معاناتها من موضوع اقتصاديه
صعبهنا الكامل واشرافنا على موضوع حاجات
القوه الامنيه هي تقوم بواجباتها بكل
وطنيه وكما انجزنا الانتخابات النيابيه
رغم التشكيك والقوه الامنيه والعسكريه
والعسكريه قامت بدورها لا تزال على القوى
الامنيه والعسكريه تقوم بدورها بي بي ظروف
حساسه وهنا استشهد لاقول بان الخطه
الامنيه التي اجريت لمدينه طرابلس نجحت
نجاحا كبيرا ان تعاطي وزاره الداخليه مع
موضوع الازمات الازمه المصريفيه والخلافات
بين المذيعين واصحاب والمصارف نجحت الى حد
كبير لم يسقط اي ضحيه وانا قلتها واقولها
دائما لن اضع القوه الامنيه في مواجهه
المواطنين اللبنانيين فكده الطرفين موجوع
ماذا عن الشبكات الارهابيه التي تم
توقيفها مؤخرا الشبكات التوقيف الشبكات
الارهابيه هو دليل نجاح للقوه الامنيه
والعسكريه الجريمه موجوده منذ التاريخ
الجريمه موجوده منذ
همم بدايه البشريه انما عندما يظهر ذلك
للعلن انما هو دليل على نشاط القوى
الامنيه ونجاحها في كشف هذه الشبكات اننا
همم نعلن عن كشف الشبكات الارهابيه في وقت
معين وفي الاوقات التي ندرسها وخدمه
لمشروع امني يحقق مصلحه اللبنانيين متى
ستضعون حدا للاتجاه والمخدرات
اننا نقوم بجهه كبير في مكافحه الانجار
بالمخدرات همم ذلك كان ملحوظا في في في
الوثيقه العربيه التي ابلغها معالي وزير
خارجيه دوله الكويت عندما زار الرؤساء
الثلاثه وزارا في وزاره الداخليه ان انا
نقوم بتفكيك شبكات تهريب المخدرات ان ان
وزاره الداخليه بالتعاون مع كل الاجهزه
الامنيه والعسكريه وجه هذا التحقيق
والتفتيش في الجمارك اللبنانيه نضبط كميات
همم همم من شحنات المخدرات التي تنتقل عبر
لبنان انا اقولها بالامن وبالسياسه ممنوع
ان يكون لبنان مصدرا للاذى لاي دوله في
العالم ولا سيما للدول العربيه الشقيقه
التي لم تميز بين اللبنانيين واخر وانما
اعطت لبنان واللبنانيين ضمن اطار منطق
الشرعيه ان الدول العربيه همم بحاجه الى
لبنان سليم ومعافى ان الدول العربيه
ولبنان معا ونحن بحاجه الى الى التكامل
والى ان تكون العلاقه بين دوله ودوله من
هنا تحرس الدول العربيه الشقيقه والراسيه
ما دول الخليج على ان تكون في لبنان دوله
بكل معنى الكلمه على ان تكون في لبنان
دوله تتمتع بصفات الدوله تحكم ارضها من
منطلق الشرعيه نحن بالنسبه الينا الجريمه
واحده والمخدرات كالارهاب
يجب مكافحته وهو ما نقوم به والى الان
بنجاح باذن الله في دقيقه واحده ومن صعب
نطلب منه ايقاظي نتحدث في دقيقه واحده
اتوجه الى القاضي وليس الى وزير الداخليه
التحقيق في
الانفجار في المرفق التحقيق في تعطيل تاخر
كثيرا طبعا التحقيق في جريمه انفجار
مرفا بيروت تاخر كثيرا كثيرا وكثيرا جدا
نحن في بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع ندعو ويجب
تطبيق الدستور وتطبيق القانون بحذافيره
همم ان النصوص القانونيه وضعت لتفعل وليس
لتعطل وان مبدا القانوني يقول ان اعمال
النص واعمال القانون خير من اهله هنا يجب
توسل همم الطرق المناسبه والقانونيه
والدقيقه لكي لكي يخرج همم هذا التحقيق من
عقاله حيث هو مع قال انا اقول تحقيق عارف
انفجار مرفا معتقل وهذا يضر بلبنان
واللبنانيين وسمعه اللبنانيين ولا سيما
سمعه جهاز العداله والقضاء في لبنان انا
اتوجه الى كل من يعنيهم الامر من سياسيين
ومن رجال قانون ومن رجال دوله ومن قضاه
والى كل المنظومه داخل لبنان
والمنظومه التي تحب لبنان ان يطلقوها هذا
التحقيق من عقاله حرام هذا الموضوع اصبح
حراما ولا يجوز ان يستمر ان هذا الانفجار
الكبير الذي اودى بمئات الضحايا وبالاف
الجرحى ودمر جزءا كبيرا من بيروت عزيزه
عاصمه لبنان والعرب يجب ان يجب ان ينتهي
الى خواتيم جيده فقط باسم العداله والحق
معالي الوزير شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لكم
تحياتي شكرا لكم على المتابعه ابقوا معنا
قناه
[موسيقى]